This paper has a ton of promise. Amazing
promises. Get this: it promises to reconstruct
3D objects from a bunch of images. It
promises better generative 3D modeling,
even creating an animated 3D model of us moving,
tetrahedral mesh geometry for physics simulation
for squishy things, and can also recommend
geometry models that are easier to 3D print.
Now, wait wait wait. This is not
new. In fact, this is old stuff,
because this was possible for 36 years now. What?
Yes, really. The legendary computer graphics paper
by the name Marching Cubes also set out to do
that. It is a simple handcrafted technique,
and it can be used for tomography,
magnetic resonance imaging and more.
It gives you everything you want. Or, Neural
Dual Contouring. A paper from just a year ago.
So why not just use them? Well, here is why.
Look. We are starting out from this sphere and
would like to morph it into this object.
Can we? Oof! Not quite! The previous Dual
Contouring technique blows up immediately.
The neural version is more well behaved,
but it can’t give us our desired shape. Marching
cubes, comes to the rescue…until it falters in
being flexible enough to reconstruct the
final shape. A good try though. So, what
about the new technique? Wow, that is a seemingly
perfect reconstruction of the desired geometry.
So, what else can it do? Well, hold
on to your papers Fellow Scholars,
because here in goes a video of a
physics simulation, this is really tough,
because but the desired geometry is
not stationary anymore. And once again,
it starts out from a ball, and over time,
wow, look! Out comes 3D geometry that we can
use in our video games and all kinds of virtual
worlds. All this from an input video. So cool!
And, it gets even better! When combined with a
text to 3D technique from just 2 years ago, here,
we can do something similar to text to image, we
write something, and out comes a painting of that,
but here, instead we write something, and out
comes…can that really be? Out comes this 3D
geometry. And the difference is that finally,
we are now getting high-quality geometry.
And get this, even creating animations is also
possible with this. That is a huge step forward.
And because this is a differentiable
mesh generation technique,
it means that it starts out from
something completely different,
and it slowly morphs into the final result over
time. I absolutely love these animations. And
this one shows that the new technique once
again, converges to the desired geometry,
we have seen that, okay, but. Wait a minute.
That is not only a better piece of geometry,
but it also uses about 20% fewer little
elements, little triangles to accomplish that.
This means that these models will require less
memory, and can be rendered faster. Fantastic!
And there is an problem here. Do you see
the problem? Well, Marching Cubes has some
more issues, for instance in the nose region here.
Thus, this geometry is typically not 3D printable,
or if so, not out of the box. And finally,
the new one can generate pieces of geometry
that don’t have these problems, and
are now more suitable for 3D printing.
Now, clearly, these are not yet the kinds
of assets that you would directly put into
those triple A quality games, not even close.
But all this is a heck of a lot of value in
just one paper. And just imagine what we will be
capable of just two more papers down the line.